okay
hello folks welcome to rational science
directly from Germany uh I've been sick
for the last three weeks especially the
last two weeks got a congestion I can't
get rid of
just a moment ago I took an aspirin and
some nose rubs see if I can talk a
little better today uh than last time
anyways and I've been on the road so um
I haven't been able to see a doctor or
anything like that so we'll find out
what's going on
uh
um anyways for the last couple weeks or
last couple times uh we've talked about
the flat lenders okay who are the
Flatlanders here let me synthesize that
okay these are the Flatlanders we got
people anywhere from the flat earthers
they're on the right all the way to the
flat uh universers on the upper left uh
all these people believe in some kind of
they have some problem with with
pancakes I guess uh they think
everything's flat and in between you
have people like you know the uh people
who talk about dimensions and two
Dimensions four dimensions all these
Dimensions uh and they make a good salad
with that and also we have the quantum
mechanics the uh etheris and the
electric universers I include them under
Flatlanders because they uh what they
propose their theories you know what
what they uh propose How the Universe
Works uh I think a lot of that belongs
all in flat land
anyways today specifically I'm gonna be
dealing with the etheris here okay and
the reason is you know they uh raised
the quite a few or put several comments
they raised a lot of questions and so I
want to address a lot of their
misconceptions okay so let's start with
them
first uh etherist right he says the
following so somehow this channel turned
from a really interesting alternative
physics channel to a hate spewing I know
better than all of you Channel which
makes it impossible to have a serious
constructive discussion on topics that
help Humanity
okay uh frustrated fellow okay okay so
this is what I gotta say to this
gentleman okay and uh here it goes uh
this fellow is a frustrated etherist
because he can't defend his beloved
ether okay that's what it's all about
that's why instead of addressing uh
substance he went after form he says oh
you said poo poo bill yeah uh you know
if you if you put more emphasis on form
than on substance I suggest that you go
visit Mr Juanito Baez there at the
University of Riverside
and the University of Riverside is
partially maintained by the state in
other words State funds and uh why is
that important well that means your tax
dollars are helping to support its
operations and there you will find uh
for the last 20 years at least the
crackpot index that Mr Baez put up there
so it's officially on their website and
it's used to be mean to
um to make fun of to ridicule anyone who
opposes especially quantum mechanics and
general relativity so if you oppose uh
mathematical physics in any way shape or
form oh they will stay you know set you
straight and the way they will do it is
by laughing at you by ridiculing you by
calling you a what a crackpot okay
you're a crackpot they won't even listen
to you okay and I like uh Point number
19 and bias's uh crackpot in this says
10 points were arguing that while the
current well-established theory predicts
phenomena correctly it doesn't explain
why they occur or fails to provide a
mechanism
yeah Mr bias that's exactly what physics
was supposed to do all the questions
that people asked for example in quora
or even in this side have to do with
mechanisms and these people give the
most irrational answer they can think of
as far as mechanism and Theory are
concerned and uh here he says well you
know uh it doesn't explain well who
cares
they don't think they don't believe
that's part of their job
responsibilities okay they they think
all they have to do is just describe not
explain mechanisms so you know anyways
you're you're paying for this uh for
these people to make fun of you so if
you have a gripe against form don't come
to my channel go to Mr bias Channel go
to the University of Riverside send them
a letter and tell them hey how come they
use that uh crackpot index to the to
belittle uh anyone who opposes
mathematical physics in any way shape or
form now he says really interesting you
know he hasn't understood a single thing
and uh especially in my criticism of
ether okay constructive you know uh uh
the construction part has to do with uh
substance not with form so you know if
you want to be constructive you know
what you should do is answer the
question what is The Ether and I I think
I made that quite clear I'm going to
make it again clear today just in case
help Humanity absolutely not what do I
propose here I'm saying that uh we are
the last humans on Earth so there is uh
no uh intention on my part to help
Humanity more uh specifically we're here
to destroy mathematical physics not to
construct anything related to anything
that's come out of mathematical physics
in the last 400 years okay so let's uh
find out what this site is about this
site is about destroying mathematical
physics and every one of their theories
every one of their explanations physical
interpretations which we dismiss as
absolute nonsense
irrationality papika and replacing it
constructively right with the Rope model
and now you have mechanisms that you can
sink your teeth into you don't have to
believe it but hopefully if you come
here you understand it that's all that's
our only hope okay we cross our fingers
that you will understand it okay here's
another etheris and he says greetings
Bill gatie
you're an ignoramus blah blah blah blah
blah okay and I just pointed out that he
misspelled your okay they say you're a
shadow piece of work okay again that's
twice now that he misspelled your so I
don't know if he can talk about ignorant
okay
uh what has he proposed The Ether is the
medium now you know I have uh more
respect for people like him okay than
the previous guy because this guy's
speaking from the heart okay and you
know you can come to this side you can
put it any comment you want as far as
I'm concerned you can cuss my mother if
you want okay I don't really care you
know if you have something to say
something that's interesting something
that I think deserves attention you know
to be addressed then I will address it
on the next uh you know uh lecture but
you can come here and put anything you
want in fact I encourage you to do so
because uh I know you're speaking from
the heart you're you're being honest but
when you come in there and you say well
you know you said poo poo and I got a
friend and you know you're in the wrong
side buddy you're in the wrong field
because you know you got to think about
something you know um
since the days of the Greeks one school
of thought would laugh and make and
ridicule the another school of thought
nothing has changed in the last three
thousand years
okay so so if you just found out that
hey you know you offended me you know
first of all we don't offend we treat
you with the respect that you deserve
but even if we offended you that's
that's exactly what the establishment
does you know all of science is like
that and they have different ways of
offending you you know quotations on
that uh one by not publishing you you
know how how's that for offensive and
the other one is uh you know they laugh
at you they belittle you and you know
and uh and and you can't get your word
out there okay if that's if you're
against the establishment right so
there's no way to beat that because they
have all the funds they have all the
controls of of the sources of power and
you're just a little guy you're nobody
that's that's the status quo so yeah at
least let me make fun of them okay
that's my little
revenge against these people okay
another fellow says ether is here he
says the ether is not made of particles
it's ubiquitous continuous fluid ether
is not composed of anything
okay we got a little bit of a problem or
at least um we're not understanding
exactly what this fellow proposes
because there you see a fluid and it
seems like it's made of Parts okay so if
it's like he says it just continuous
whatever he means by that made a we say
that that means made of a single piece
if it's not made of parts right then
this is what he's got to answer there
your ether it's made of a single piece
in this case I put a block uh uh you
know a elongated Cube no problem you can
put a sphere if you want put whatever
you want in there you can color it any
way you want as well I'll call that The
Ether it's a continuous block made of a
single piece I need to know what the
white stuff is I don't care about the
block I want to know what gives shape to
this single uh piece entity made of a
single piece okay so unless he can
answer that question you know he's he
said nothing so far
okay how about another fella he says the
following see if we can get him up here
says uh deither is made of an infinite
amount of infinitely small part uh
objects in other words the first guy
said it's not made of Parts this guy
says it is made of parts and that gives
you an idea of where all these etherists
stand you know you can't get a single
you know group of people to agree on
what the ether is because they've never
pondered what the ether is they just
want to use it they say
this okay yeah I understood a lot with
that okay so it says The Ether fills all
of space nothing well uh he it can't
fill space because space is not a
container if you're gonna define space
as nothing nothing is not a container
something is a container so The Ether
cannot fill all of space first of all
second you haven't told me whether the
ether or space is infinite meaning
extends forever or not or if it stops
somewhere what's on the outside of it
and we have the same situation as before
you know you got to tell me what's
outside of the block
uh waves are not objects they are motion
okay he's right about that correct and
he says in the case of light waves it is
the motion of the ether
now I've got a little problem there okay
he says in the case of light waves it is
the motion of The Ether okay so there
you have The Ether it's made out of
infinite amount of small particles okay
that's what he's saying uh apparently
he's saying that it's some kind of
physical object therefore it has to have
shape it has to stop somewhere it's got
to be finite right made of infinite
particles but it itself has to be finite
unless he can you know otherwise it's
not a physical object okay it's not a
thing
you can't use it as a thing okay so
what's the problem with what he's saying
here he says that is the motion of The
Ether okay so let's start slowly so that
you can understand the reasoning okay
here we have a table
and we have a portion of the table and
it's waving okay some portion of the
wave of the table is waving
can you say that the table is waving
okay because these people say the ether
is infinite it's extended it's the whole
universe it fills up space The Ether is
vibrating The Ether it's the motion of
the ether
well here we have the where the problem
is you can't say that that portion of
the table that region of the table which
is moving there you know it could be
atoms could be the crystal structure of
the table could be the wood could be
whatever but Mom's saying there's a
region of the table that's vibrating
and so the question is is can you say
that the table is vibrating
or should you say that a region of the
table a segment apart a a portion of the
table is Right vibrating
okay so this is the issue okay now
here's the ether okay
okay can we say that the whole ether the
whole universe is vibrating
or is light the vibration a localized
vibration of The Ether
in which case you know you have light
going this way you have light going that
way and light going in different
directions through the ether or being
The Ether itself that's vibrating no
problem but then that means it's made of
parts that's the first one okay it's
like you said infinite amount apart no
such thing as infinite in science
because he's using the word infinite
which is an adjective to qualify not uh
um the particle is saying that there's
countless he's saying that's incessant
counting of particles that's what he
means by infinite infinite can only be
an object and all objects are finite
therefore the word infinite is an
irrational term should never be used in
science
so these people have not understood how
to talk that's the first problem they're
using adjectives to qualify counting
which is you know in this case turns uh
this adjective into an adverb okay
okay let me remove this give me a second
here
[Music]
okay here we have another etherus along
the same lines he says yes if the poor
if a portion of the ether vibrates that
is still The Ether
okay same issue just that we would say
that sound wave is a vibration of the
atmosphere when only a part of the
atmosphere vibrates there is no parts
and ether The Ether is the parts
okay so same issue
here we have the table is the table the
same thing as the part of the table I
mean if we talk about one of the legs
and we call it leg right of the table it
lagged the same thing as table
you know and this is the issue here and
here we have a portion of the table that
is vibrating for whatever reason only
one portion you know it's uh made out of
liquid or whatever can we say that the
table is vibrating
and once again you know can we say that
the ether is vibrating here is it the
whole universe that's vibrating here
so this is the issue the issue is these
people
um are confusing a portion of something
with that something itself with a whole
something
you're not allowed to do that in physics
you have to identify the region and you
have to give it a name so we can say the
third and now we have a a is not ether a
is a portion of the ether localized
region uh and you have to identify what
what it is that's vibrating you know you
can't say it's The Ether vibrate no what
you have is uh maybe particles that are
going up and down
and if they're particles which is what
they usually imply when they say that's
made out of countless parts right then
they have to tell me you know uh what
gives shape to each one of those parts
in other words what's the black stuff in
this case
the white stuff are the parts one of the
what's the black part that keeps
separated all these parts
so until you finish defining exactly
what you mean by Ether or illustrating
it we have no idea what you mean by
Ether okay these people wanna uh you
know go through this real quickly like
yeah it's a fluid
[Music]
doesn't work that way in science you got
to spend two years explaining to us or
illustrating what the ether is right and
then we'll listen to your irrelevant
theory about gravity or whatever you
want to explain
spend time on your ether we don't know
what the ether is yet and we have all
these different opinions different
versions okay so be very clear uh it's
very easy to also put a link to either
your website or some other website where
they have an illustration of The Ether
if you want to illustrate The Ether no
problem okay but what I do recommend
is for uh you know doing images search
in Google and uh look for The Ether
you know put ether in there you'll see
what people have in their minds you know
what they think ether is you'll find a
hundred different versions so now nobody
has any idea what the ether is that's
why I like to tell them what the ether
is and if they don't like it they have
to tell me why my ether is not their
ether or the traditional ether the one
that was used in the 19th century to
talk about the undulation of light
okay here we have another info it says
either can be treated like a Continuum
aha at all levels because it is made of
what an infinite amount of objects
so this fellow thinks that he Continuum
is simply something that is made of an
infinite amount of things okay so I have
to Define for him what continuous means
because people use these words they
don't even know what they're talking
about
continues is something made of a single
piece that's what continuous means in
physics I don't care what it means in
the religion of math I don't care what
it means in everyday speech continues in
physics made of a single piece it's an
adjective it refers to an object that is
made of a single piece okay
now uh what these people want to do is
use the word Continuum continuous
continually they want to use it as
Perpetual or Eternal as synonyms of
these words it could be Perpetual means
that it doesn't stop moving or Eternal
never stops existing okay like it's yeah
at some point something stops existing
well or you know disappears somehow
these people are saying that Eternal
essentially is never stops existing and
here you have synonyms of these words
more or less incessant constant non-stop
here we're talking about motion and they
use the word continuous to talk about
motion that's where the problem is
continues can never be used for motion
okay so this is where the problem is and
then you have endless like if you're
talking about an object okay that's an
infinite object and there's no such
monster because an object is that which
has shape therefore it's an oxymoron so
self-contradiction to say an endless
object or an infinite object and uh in
the religion of General activity they
use the term finite but unbounded and
again the finite part usually refers to
the object all objects are finite but
when they talk about the unbounded which
is an adjective you know bounded it's an
adjective should be used to again it
means an object that that has no shape
because uh you can't see the shape you
can't see how it's bounded okay but what
they use unbounded for is something
totally different and it's uh again it's
used for incessant as a synonym of
incessant or Perpetual they're saying
that the motion around the object is
unbounded you'll never find a wall
that's what they mean by unbounded so uh
they try to get this Duality through to
you saying it's finite by an unbounded
Universe no such monster in physics okay
they have a contradiction in their terms
they're doing word solid you know as
it's called uh semantics
okay it says continuums aren't actual
objects but rather mathematical
representations of a group of objects
what Behavior
okay so is Continuum related to behavior
or to objects
okay so we have we have a problem here
because this fellow goes back and forth
he doesn't even know what he's saying if
it's a if it's got to do with behavior
then it's they should not use the word
continuum and then he he clarified says
a Continuum is not an actual fluid
because fluids are made of more than one
thing okay I thought that's what they
Define Continuum as uh something made of
many things
most ether theorists have defined ethers
being made of many possibly infinite
amount of particles again all these
people use the word infinite when uh
infinite is an adjective should never be
used in science at all anytime a person
uses the word infinite we call him an
idiot it is a person with big ideas
okay okay and no we're not offending
them we're treating him with the respect
that he deserves
okay here we have another phone he says
you're still messing with the usual word
solid again he thinks uh all this is
just some antiques okay my ether
mechanism about fluid dynamics very
rational so he declares his own Theory
very irrational okay yet you totally
rejected makti ether yes until you do
the word salad semantics
okay these people want to avoid language
because they're not good at right at all
they don't Define words at all they
don't care about definition they say you
know what I mean by Ether no I don't
and so we need to for you to tell us
exactly what you mean by Ether and if
it's an object we want you to point to
it we want a drawing we want to picture
snapshot whatever you can get a statue
you know bring it to the conference
and it says take the time damn time to
read and I answer take the time damn
time to listen because he says you still
haven't answered the question tell me
what your ropes are made of it's already
been two three times that I said rope is
equal to two threads two threads you go
to the hardware store you ask for a row
what will they give you well they'll
give you a maybe uh if it's a two strand
rope right and they'll give you two
twined uh threads strands wires whatever
you want strings whatever you want to
call them two threads okay that's what a
rope is made out of if you've never
learned that in kindergarten please go
to your nearest hardware store and ask
for a two-strand rope and you'll find
out what a rope is made out of two
strands
but this is what these people have to
answer okay and this is what they're
none of them can do and they haven't
done so so far uh these are their action
items is it an object or a concept and
if you don't know the difference well
you gotta uh go to kindergarten and
learn what an object is and why what a
concept is object just in general terms
is that which has shaped concept is that
which doesn't that's not the definition
of concept but we need to know if what
you're referring to has shape or not
essentially Concepts we uh we Define
objects we illustrate we do not
illustrate Concepts we do not Define
objects you do not Define table you
point to it so that the Klingon knows
what the word table refers to okay
then you got to tell me whether ether is
equal to space or ether is not equal to
space okay right now we have different
opinions out there what the ether is
okay
uh you know whether whether ether in
space are synonyms or whether if there's
something contained within space right
and again uh space equal is space finite
in other words is The Ether finite and
if space is the container you know uh we
need to know what what's containing
space because if space is a container
it's a physical object you know like a
trash can that's called a container and
there's something outside of that trash
can to give it shape okay we need to
know what that outside thing is that's
the one we're interested in
um is it made out of a single piece or
made out of particles
does it have motion this ether thingy
with respect to Wood and again is is it
the ether or a region of The Ether that
you're going to be moving okay and again
here we have the the comparison okay if
you can't say the table is uh vibrating
it's a portion of the table that's
vibrating if that's your notion of The
Ether we need for you to identify very
well what it is that's vibrating you
know in the case of uh The Ether what is
that squiggly line that's moving at that
wave you know if if you say that the
ether is vibrating you're saying the
whole universe is vibrant that's not
what you're referring to you're saying
the region of the ethers vibrating for
that you need to identify that region
tell me what it's made out of what's the
white stuff what's the black stuff okay
you need every little thing you can't
just Skip and say well it's The Ether
you know that that doesn't solve our
problem okay
okay
uh and finally we have uh another fellow
he says the following is space is
nothing
that is my definition I literally said
what you said
you just want to disagree for the sake
of disagreeing according to you
something is that which has shape yeah
if that if there's something I say then
the nothing I shape around it I
therefore nothing is that which has
shape it's a stupid definition yeah I
agree with you uh what you just said is
a stupid definition you didn't
understand squat okay so let's clarify
here we have something on the upper
right
and it's enclosed within nothing which
we call space this vowel says that
nothing has shape so we want to know
because he says it has shape because
it's encapsulating something not because
it itself is being encapsulated by the
green stuff
and shape is what's on the outside not
on the inside but he doesn't understand
that okay so so the issue is that he's
got to identify the green stuff that is
encapsulating nothing just in case on
the bottom we get rid of the something
and the green stuff and we have only
nothing so he says that nothing has
shape
okay and I put it as a circle or oval
there uh it doesn't matter you can put a
cube if you want I don't care I need to
know what the white stuff that it's
encapsulating nothing is okay that's how
simple it is and here's our version of
that okay okay uh let me get back in
here
something that which has shape okay
synonyms object thing anything body
structure entity medium Etc et cetera
Etc nothing but there's nothing nothing
now which doesn't have shape
so there are antonyms something is the
opposite of nothing now we can use these
words consistently rationally in physics
physical interpretations mechanisms
right because now we have defined these
words unambiguously something that which
has shape nothing that which doesn't
antonyms no problem okay uh nothing is
the same thing as space space and
nothing are exactly the same thing space
is a word we give to nothing
okay
so space is that which doesn't have
shape you can call vacuum void
nothingness doesn't matter all these are
synonyms okay
um something you should be able to point
at it in a single frame of the universal
movie there is no motion
some people say well Bill all objects
you know have electrons and electrons
are moving these people are mentally
handicapped that's what they are we're
talking about a single frame of the
universal movie nothing is moving in a
photograph that's what we have so far in
front of us we have location only we
have distance between objects distance
and location are both static concept
there is nothing moving in that frame of
the film
so even though electrons move every day
from one time to another from one motion
to another from one location to another
that's not what we're talking about
we're saying we we're going to have a
cross section of time we're going to cut
the universe right there at the Cutting
Edge which of events right we call that
the now the present uh whatever else you
synonyms you want to put in there there
is no motion
in a single frame of the universal movie
okay so we have an object there that's
something it's not moving not a single
atom not a single electron is moving
there because we have a snapshot nothing
moves in a slap shot hopefully unless
you've drank too much beer okay nothing
is the one on the right and there's
nothing we can illustrate it with
because you cannot illustrate nothing
because nothing is that which doesn't
have shape see how simple it was okay
okay the first law of the universe
something can't morph into nothing and
nothing can't morph into something
there could have been no beginning to
the universe to matter
and there will be no end because
hopefully uh something cannot turn into
space in other words something cannot
suddenly spontaneously lose length width
and height and become nothing
likewise nothing cannot acquire
spontaneously you know
surreptitiously acquire life width and
height and become
something
okay
okay we don't only have uh some of the
etheris we also have some other flat
Landers around here and let's look at
them here we have one flat Lander and he
says the following okay
says uh well he said this before okay
this was a comment he put a couple weeks
ago said uh quoting Professor Mueller
from um Berkeley University okay gravity
goes right through things and Israel
says what like a ghost through a wall
and so I had to clarify that uh what
Professor Mueller was referring to was
Newton's equation Force equals
gravitational constant G Mass 1 times
mass 2 divided by distance Square okay
that's the universal uh gravitational
formula okay and so when I explained
that in the last
um uh lecture
then he put a different comment he said
oh okay gravity goes through things like
you me and the Earth yeah that's better
okay so now he acknowledged that gravity
goes through things that's what Newton's
equation depicts that's what it uh it is
describing okay but then he says but
gravity pulls on things like you me and
the Earth total contradiction no
rationale misspelled right or a reason
given
okay uh let's find out let's continue
here with this file and he says Newton's
equation a description not an
explanation of gravity absolutely
correct yeah yeah he figured one out
yeah it's a description mathematics any
equation is only a description
mathematics has no power to explain
anything that's why so-called
mathematical physicists never explained
anything okay they never explained to
have no right to explain to him no no
special insight to explain they can
describe mathematically but they cannot
explain the causes the mechanisms that's
why we have all all
um mechanisms today all theories today
coming from mathematical physics are
irrational
yeah for for invisible intangible
mediators right or events okay he says
you have said nothing new to me well I
guess he wasn't paying attention because
there he says he continually says you
provide no explanation for acceleration
of objects in your rope model aha
changing only the angles of the ropes
from a coaxial to Fanning out as
demonstrated by your simulation does not
explain change in momentum
well I wasn't trying to explain change
and momentum I was trying to explain
gravity okay uh he called it change in
momentum maybe he was thinking about
something else okay I was trying to
explain the acceleration of gravity okay
from a physical point of view I was
trying to explain a mechanism I
Illustrated it he didn't understand it
he says that the fact that I went from
uh angles to Fanning out you know a
single angle to or a single coaxial to
Fanning out did not explain gravity as
far as he was concerned
you state weight is static correct
weight is a static concept then he says
changeless I don't know what he means by
change this I didn't say change this
this is his uh irrational interpretation
of what weight is static means wait is
that it means that weight is a static
concept means that you have weight for a
single location anywhere in the universe
anywhere in the universe you have a
given weight with respect to something
else okay and we'll get into that in a
second in more detail
yet when the location of an object
changes weight changes yeah see again
he's he's talking about the word change
that's not what we're talking about
we're saying weight is static and if you
move to another location static location
you have a different weight okay so you
do change weight okay you do change
weight that's why this changeless is
something he misunderstood
that is a description not an explanation
again he missed the whole boat okay an
explanation that a child can understand
like a rope pulling a donkey well I
guess he's got to go back to
kindergarten because he did not
understand the explanation which was
exactly like a rope pulling a donkey
okay now where does his ignorance uh and
arrogance right uh originate well it
originates here okay and this is
important to see in his case explanation
is the domain of religion
okay so he thinks an explanation a
mechanism right of how something uh
happened for example you know uh a kid
through a stone through the window and
we see the window on the floor and we
say how did this happen and if Paul says
well uh Stone went through the window or
a brick went through a window
and that's an explanation that's a
mechanism of how the glass ended up on
the floor he says that's religion
okay
now he can tell you he says neither
Galileo or Darwin could explain their
observations and I'll include Newton
area he they freely admitted they only
describe what they observed and yeah all
these people uh mathematicians they
never could explain anything so they
only described
right in the case of Darwin I would make
an exception I would say that he did
explain okay but that's I'm not going to
get into that my point is that in
mathematics okay uh people like Galileo
Newton they only describe because all
they did was equations and in the case
of uh Galileo he uh he did a lot of
description verbal descriptions without
having to go into equations but they
were again descriptions okay he never
explained why the causes of gravity he
just explained this is what it does
and then you can see it says religion a
topic of today right has a long recorded
history of wrong predictions okay I
guess he's referring to general
relativity and quantum mechanics because
general relativity predicted that matter
arose out of nothing you know Big Bang
Theory so I don't know how that
prediction uh you know in retrospect
right retrospect prediction happened I
don't know how they can predict that a
black hole which is a Zero Dimensional
nothing
uh attracts you know a star or swallows
a star or swallows matter so all the
predictions of these people are wrong
how how can a particle be of two places
at once so all these predictions from
so-called science mathematical physics
you know uh they're they're all
irrational let alone wrong
many lies were are and will be improved
because of better ways to predict events
in the future well I don't know what
prediction has to do with anything at
all why he even mentioned this what's it
got to do with Improvement he's talking
about I guess uh technology and he
thinks technology has something to do
with science okay without any
explanation required explanations only
satisfy those who demand answers that
can't be questioned
okay again none of that has anything to
do with science science is exclusively
explaining
that's what science is you have to break
your brain to explain especially the
invisible intangible world of Mother
Nature and you don't have to believe it
but you do have to explain it you have
to explain the mechanism so that someone
understands what you're proposing for
How the Universe works so if someone
says how does gravity work for example
why doesn't the Earth fly out of the
solar system
you got to give an explanation to that
question
and for that you have to have a
mechanism it doesn't mean that the
listener is going to believe in your
mechanism it means you provide one so
that he understands what you're
proposing now you can say look angels
are pushing the Earth around the Sun
okay that's your version
we understand it you draw the angel you
show him pushing the Earth around the
Sun we understood it
okay we have your explanation for how
you think the earth goes around the sun
no problem
but it doesn't mean that the listener is
going to believe that explanation but
you do have an explanation and uh for
this well to say that all explanations
are religion
uh uh
obviously he's not going to understand
anything that I teach here I don't even
know what he's doing here he's got the
brain to you know to clean the trains at
the bus stop you know I don't know what
what he's doing in a science uh Channel
okay what what answers is he looking for
if he's not looking for explanations
okay so let's explain to him what he
missed okay and let's explain maybe the
second time he gets it you never know
okay or third time because I think this
is the third time
he says my stupid inquires and arrogant
assumptions make me laugh yeah not only
you we're all laughing so
keep going uh your great stand-up
comedian okay I don't mean to come off
arrogant have you have some compassion
Bill we all can't be Geniuses like you
yeah these people are Ultra arrogant and
ignorant and
um you know they they say oh I'm not
arrogant I'm not but see this is it
shows in every word that they pronounce
they don't fool anyone okay so yeah I
don't have any problem with dealing with
all these people you know that's why
when some people come here and say oh
you said poo poo bill you called me a
poo poo
my God you know uh grow up that's all I
can tell you okay here's uh where we
start we have Mueller again Mr uh
what is it Richard Mueller from Berkeley
University and this is what he said okay
and I think I've got the link there uh
you can look it up
says the following he says
um every animal on Earth on the earth is
pulling on every atom of you you're also
pulling on it the amazing thing about
gravity is that it goes right through
things
okay so what does what problem does this
fellow have he says how can you be
pulling
at the same thing as going right through
things that's where he's got his what he
what he thinks is a contradiction or
irrationality in his mind okay because
again he's thinking of particles
probably and he says okay the particle
goes through you that he can understand
maybe they're invisible particles
whatever and
intangible party goes okay no problem
but then how do they pull so this is
what he can't understand okay
so um how do we answer okay well first
let's Show an example here okay here we
see that uh the uh gravity which is that
yellow line okay we're just representing
it with a yellow line and what we're
saying is that gravity somehow goes
through everything goes through the wall
goes through you goes through the ball
behind you and keeps going whatever
gravity is it traverses everything you
can't put a shield in front of you an
anti-gravity Shield because it'll pull
you right through the shield and the
shield with you okay so there you can't
Shield yourself from Gravity anywhere in
the universe there is no such thing as
an
um a gravity Shield okay anti-gravity
that's something else that's called life
yeah life is anti-gravity but uh gravity
Shield there's nothing in the universe
God has not invented it yet okay and
[Music]
um
so here's uh the situation okay here we
have the Earth okay this is what we're
going to explain to this gentleman okay
here we have the Earth and we have it at
two locations we will assume right that
the Earth could be closer to the Sun or
much farther away case number one you're
far away case number two you're closer
to the Earth and to the sun if the Earth
is closer to the Sun assuming we could
do that if we could move the Earth
somehow closer to the Sun it would weigh
more with respect to the Sun than where
it's at right now
okay that's what Newton's equation tells
us that's that distance Square in the
denominator okay do we have that do we
understand that equation the equation
says that the farther away you are the
less you weigh
okay
okay now uh we need to clarify that it's
a question of
um location and again we have to clarify
that location is a static concept
location occupies a single frame in the
Universal movie location is just a bunch
of distances another static concept
right between atoms we're not talking
about distance traveled we're talking
about which is the mathematical distance
we're talking about distance of physics
separation there's separation between
any two objects in the universe okay so
we're seeing if we look at a single
frame not even an electron is moving in
that frame nothing is moving it's a
snapshot it's a picture it's a
photograph whatever other word you want
to uh painting you know whatever word
you want to use here okay so we're
saying that in one case we're saying
that weight is a static concept there is
no no motion whatsoever if you're just
far away from the Sun you have a certain
weight and if you are closer to the Sun
in just a single frame of that movie you
wait more weight is a static concept
there is no motion required for weight
okay I hope uh that I don't know how
else to clarify that for at least for
intelligent people people who have
problem mental problems well they might
have a little bit of problem they don't
understand what I'm talking about how do
we explain this how is it possible okay
that if you're farther away from the Sun
you weigh less at one location snapshot
not even electron moves nothing moves
it's a cross-section of time in the
universe it's the Now The Cutting Edge
of events anyway you want to visualize
it how come you weigh less there and you
weigh more
if you were closer to the Sun static
location
a certain separation from you and the
sun no motion no electrons moves picture
snapshot same thing same issue
how is it that you weigh less over here
how is it that you weigh more over here
we're now talking about motion it's not
that you moved okay we're saying if we
take a snapshot you weigh more here way
less here and you weigh more here
that's what we're saying closer to the
Sun you weigh more at a location static
concept farther away you wait less
that's what Newton's equation tells you
the distance in the denominator is not
distance traveled there's no Motion in
that distance it's separation between
two masses which are in the numerator
okay and someone following me out there
okay how do we explain it here we have
it we explain where ropes okay
it's not only the angle as this
individual insinuated there it's more
than that we have more effective ropes
okay now I the way I did it here is just
for illustration I showed fewer ropes on
the way less on a scenario number one
and I put more ropes okay on number two
what did uh Mr Richard Mueller say he
says that every atom of the sun is
pulling on every atom of the Earth every
atom on Earth is pulling on every atom
of the Sun that means every atom in the
earth is connected to every atom of the
Sun and vice versa what happens with
these ropes which are the ones that are
connecting every single atom of these
two objects what happens when the earth
comes closer to the Sun Well the ropes
fan out you have more effective ropes
you have more effective ropes the number
of ropes has not changed in the universe
what changes effective ropes for this
specific event what do we mean by
effective rows
let's go through that okay here's the
definition of effective rope we have a
cube and we have a cylinder the cube has
five atoms we don't care about all the
others and the cylinder has one atom
number six there okay all the atoms in
in the cube are a line on the same axis
exactly on the same axis okay they're
all connected to atom number six along
the same axis that means all the ropes
are superimposed one on top of the other
one inside the other ropes have no
ability to touch ropes touch is
forbidden in Mother Nature's universe
that is the Assumption okay so no ropes
can touch another rope they can
superimpose just like in Quantum two
particles can be at the same location
right here the same thing two ropes can
be exactly at the same location at the
same time okay do we have that so we
have one effective rope as far as uh the
cylinder is concerned it just sees one
rope because all these five atoms are on
the same axis what happens when the
distance changes it's not motion we're
talking about we're talking about
separation the separation chains
suddenly the cylinder is closer to the
cube you see what happened to the six to
the five ropes somehow they fanned out
now each one is pulling you could say
pulling right uh individually separate
from the axis okay where they were
before so now you have what we call five
effective ropes and that's why the
attraction of gravity is stronger
okay so with those five uh different
local ropes uh effective ropes you pull
more or you have more uh Stronger
gravity than you had with one rope okay
on the right hand side upper right there
you can see a general picture two
objects very far apart from each other
all the ropes superimpose and form a
single coaxial you could say so uh if
you know you can look at maybe the
nearest star it's so far away that all
the Rope superimpose and that's why
gravity is weak because they all act
like one single rope almost okay what
happens when the objects approach each
other well you can see what's happening
to the ropes they're not they are no
longer on the same axis so it's not only
the angle it's that you have more
effective ropes okay so that's the
theory the reason for gravitational
acceleration has to do with the ropes
Fanning out and meaning that we have
more effective ropes you want to use
another word use another word I use the
word effective ropes okay
anyways
uh all I can say to this fellow is
please try to understand before one of
us dies as Mr Faulty Towers uh basil fog
faulty sudden Faulty Towers okay so
please try to understand before one of
us dies okay and we do have uh we do
have our way of educating of learning
them okay we're going to learn you okay
yes anyways
um that's the acceleration of gravity
now one person asks you a decent
question okay so we're going to address
that one okay which is an important
question a lot of people have this in
the back of their minds if they have
Nash so far okay I said you said your
ropes are non-tangible uh-huh
so why would you say atoms are made uh
your robes of your ropes when we know
that atoms are tangible uh-huh good
question the Rope is pushed by the atom
okay well not really pushed by the atom
remember the atom slides along the Rope
but this uh let's continue here this
means the atoms are tangible to the Rope
it's not tangible it's that the Rope
becomes the atom okay so let's just
clarify that but that's not the question
I want to answer I want to answer the
the first part there how can the Rope
be
intangible and it creates something like
an atom which is tangible that's a valid
question okay under the Rope model it
seems that sometimes ropes are tangible
but sometimes they are not for example
in the case of magnetism ropes are
tangible with each other
not robes again people are not paying
attention it's threads
okay the Rope is not a thread the thread
is not a rope two threads are necessary
to make a rope you twine two threads one
around the other you'll make a rope you
untwine a rope you have a thread people
keep talking about rope Theory and
thread uh bringing you know rope into
magnetism ropes are not the ones that
are swinging in magnetism it's the
threads please get that right it means
you're you're not even paying attention
Okay okay but let's answer the first
part of this uh uh question here or
uh concern okay
first we're going to consult Mother
Nature let's ask her let's see how she
does tangibility okay because if robes
and threads are intangible you know and
they construct atoms and they also in
the case of threads they make up the
walls that comprise magnetism you know
and you have some interaction there you
know then the question is how does
Mother Nature do this how does she take
intangibility and turn it into
tangibility that's what people want to
understand that's what they want to do
okay so let's ask Mother Nature and she
says I produce tangibility through
aggregation
okay we're going to produce tangibility
through aggregation
okay that's how she does tangible
okay touchable
tangibility okay what do we mean by that
okay here we go okay here's the Rope
constr the
construction of an atom okay look at it
carefully try to understand we don't
care if you believe or not we want you
to understand that's very hard to get
people to understand okay here's the
atom how's it constructed okay we have
the electric thread that goes through
the atom forms the proton dandelion a
little star that's in the center of the
atom
the center of the atom is not a little
ball or you could say it is but it's
made up of all these rays that are
actually threads coming from every atom
in the universe every atom in the
universe okay some people say well how
can that possibly be at all these atoms
in the universe you got gazillions of
them and they converge Upon Our atom and
built this tiny little thing with all
these threads and ropes from every atom
in the universe yeah ropes do not have
the ability to touch threads do not have
the ability to touch
until you understand that you will not
make any progress okay so yes they do
not have the you have to forget about
touch okay touch is our macro world
meaning Adam and above okay below Adam
there is no such thing as touch Mother
Nature never invented touch for her
mediators which are the ropes which uh
construct the atom there you see the
roasting pinching on the electron shell
the red line there okay here you see one
more time okay magnetic thread goes
around encapsulates the proton star and
comes out the other end as a um as
another rope and you have all these
ropes from every atom in the universe
converging upon our atom and one thread
goes through the center fills the proton
star okay and this is more or less what
it looks like in big big picture okay so
we got the construction
we don't want you to believe it we want
you to accept it as an assumption okay
this is what we're going to start with
we're going to put this assumption
okay so here we go this is what our atom
looks like 2D on the left side 3D on the
right hand side okay all the ropes in
every from every atom in the universe
converts Upon Our atom one thread we'll
call it the blue thread the electric
thread this is uh this is just arbitrary
okay uh goes through the center of the
atom and builds this uh star-like entity
looks like a a
rolled up urchin you know pointing its
uh quills to every atom in the universe
right and the other uh the red one in
this case the what we call the magnetic
thread goes around and encapsulates you
know the uh proton star so you have a 2d
version you have the 3D version to get
an idea what we are proposing okay do
you believe it we don't care this is
what we're proposing so that you
understand the theory found it upon it
okay here we have
um our atom okay
and again you can see that the atom is
especially the electron shell which is
the encapsulating medium right the
membrane it's built by countless threads
okay do we have that thread from every
atom in the universe from every rope in
the universe converging upon our atom
one thread in this case the blue or
light blue thread
goes around builds our electron shell
electron membrane that membrane is going
to encapsulate inside there the proton
star
do we have that okay that's what we're
proposing do you believe it we don't
care we're not talking about belief here
we're talking about assumptions we want
you to recognize or understand the
exception assumption so that you can
follow the presentation and understand
the theories found it upon it okay here
we move forward and what you have to
understand that those threads are not
standing still it's not a ball of yarn
in a sense okay it's they're moving
around okay so when we talk about uh you
know all these
um threads that converge Upon Our
electron shell the electron shell is a
dynamic entity it's constantly moving
around because the the threads are
scanning they're uh sweeping around the
entire shell so they're they're
constantly in motion that's why people
think that the electron uh is moving
okay the electron in quantum mechanics
is just one little dot one location
there and they can say they say well we
don't know where it's at of course you
don't know where it's at because it's
kind of like everywhere because the
electron is not a tiny ball it's a bunch
of threads that are weaving around the
atom forming the electron shell and uh
the threads are in motion they're
sweeping around they're swinging around
the
surface of the atom okay so this is more
or less what we're proposing do you
believe it we don't care if you do or
not
the electron is not like that and it was
standing still okay the electron has
these
um
threads sweeping constantly around okay
and I think the at least we're proposing
that the electron shell is pretty much
as close as you get to a perfect
circular or spherical object okay now I
mean it's rough rough surface it looks
more or less like that okay so it's like
a ball of yarn in that sense but the
Yarns are Dynamic they're moving around
this thing is in constant motion in fact
great speeds
okay so um how about uh
[Music]
magnetism here we have magnetism okay
and again how does she produce Mother
Nature she produces magnetism or or what
is called a magnetic field with
aggregation
is it with ropes no it's done with
threads now we're talking about threads
okay do not confuse the thread with the
Rope two threads make a rope half a rope
is a threat okay more or less you got
that okay so here it is we have the
threads swinging around I didn't draw
all the threads we're talking about
gazillions of threads here okay from a
magnet but they're sweeping around like
walls okay walls of threads and yeah
when you have that aggregation many
threads forming walls and all these
walls sweeping around at Great speeds
well then threads go through threads but
at the same time they create this
friction because of the aggregation here
it is again I have drawn every thread so
please do not criticize me for that okay
here it is you have two magnets okay and
you can see what's doing what the
threads are doing they're sweeping
around there's countless of these and
even though you see thread we're talking
about really walls of threads okay and
they're sweeping around when you turn
the magnet around okay so that uh
clockwise uh well first we still have
attraction when you just roll it
sideways but when you turn it uh 180
degrees we can see what happens they
push each other away wide because the
threads are banging against each other
now okay so we have attraction okay
both clockwise at the top both
counterclockwise at the bottom okay you
can see what's happening if you turn it
sideways nothing changes but when you
turn it 180 degrees we should have
repulsion and we do because why because
now the threads aren't going in the
opposite direction
okay so that's the mechanism
okay
um
uh think of it as a flip book okay
here's a flip book
and you can see what's happening we're
saying that the threads form these pages
okay so that's your magnetic fields or
um walls that form the magnetic field
the whole thing the whole book is the
magnetic field and it's uh something
goes on continuously okay it doesn't
stop
yeah unless it loses strength yeah
that's a long story but think of it as a
flip book and what happens when you put
two flip books side by side well you get
something like this okay the one on the
left is going counterclockwise all the
pages okay and when on the right is also
going counterclockwise what happens when
the pages on the right hand side of the
first one of the one on the left pages
on the right hand side go up the pages
on the left hand side of the second one
go down and that's when they interact
because what are we talking about we're
talking about countless threads forming
walls which form the so-called magnetic
field magnetic field is a dynamic entity
okay as Mr
uh Maxwell said you know in that region
magnetic field there is matter in
Emotion matter in motion
an exotic type of matter for sure but
matter in motion okay and so yeah uh
that's when you produce tangibility you
produce tangibility first when you have
aggregation in the case of the electron
shell okay you have all these threads
that are moving around okay now you have
a surface so you can put one atom
against another and it will touch and
likewise uh for uh magnets you know you
have two magnets
and here we have these two little
magnets okay and what's in there are
countless threads that you cannot see or
touch right with your hand yeah you can
you can touch them with iron filings but
you can't touch them with your hand okay
because your hand is not subject to that
type of magnetic field there that's a
long story but the point is there you
have a magnetic field what did Maxwell
say about a magnetic field well there is
matter in motion that's what a magnetic
field is don't talk to me about a static
magnetic field because even a static
magnetic field has matter in motion
okay static magnetic field has matter in
Motion in there and uh so what's
happened why do they attract because one
is going this way
and the other one's going to so they're
both going in the same direction let's
see what they'll say here they're both
going like that right
so as this one comes down this one's
coming up
okay
remember this one comes down this one
comes up that's what's happening and
that friction is what countless friction
because you have one wall right after
another that's what pulls these uh
magnets together and the closer they are
together more threads more walls of
threads intervene because now they're
closer to each other now the atoms that
are farther away are closer together
also those are also engaging in the
action and now the strength of the
attraction is greater and the closer
they are the more you know you have a
stronger attraction so you know it
explains quite well the Rope model where
the threads swinging threads explains
quite well attraction between two
magnets and repulsion you have a
mechanism now but with by saying you
know giving you an equation I I you know
we have not we have described but we
have not explained how Mother Nature
does that magic trick okay
okay
so let's move on to religion the topic
of today and what do we have for
religion well you know if you ask um
the man on the street the first guy you
stop
say what is religion
you'll probably say that's something
related to God belief in God
that's typically what people have in the
back of their minds in fact if you go to
the Stanford encyclopedia philosophy
you'll find like four or five articles
on Religion different topics of religion
they all talk about the belief in God
how to prove God does God exist
so everybody's got anyways in the back
of their mind that religion has to do
something with God and with
um believing in God right that's that's
essentially what religion is from you
could say a practical or pragmatic point
of view okay okay so this is what people
think of when they think of religion you
think some kind of God out there and
they pray to this God and this thing out
there this human-like creature
anthropomorphic uh creature and they
pray uh for salvation for favors to win
the lottery who knows what they pray for
okay so this is the general notion okay
of what people understand by religion of
course when um when theists and people
who do investigations research on um
religion get involved well they say
that's not exactly what religion is
about and they have more sophisticated
Notions of religion but the first first
thing you have to understand is that at
least that's the common notion out there
and some religions like Buddhism
especially they claim they Pride
themselves saying that we do not believe
in gods or God
okay they have a totally different
philosophy uh idea of what their what
religion is or what their religion is
about
they talk about Consciousness and how to
achieve enlightenment and all this other
stuff and say well they don't deal with
gods they don't believe in God
absolute lie
absolute lie Buddhists believe in God's
God Gods whatever
Buddhas are no different than any other
religion
okay so let's prove that to the
Buddhists okay people who say we don't
believe in God you're lying you're not a
Buddhist if you don't believe in God
okay
so let's let's make sure that we
understand that portion first okay here
we have the Buddha
he says I don't believe in God
and I do believe in the tripitaka
what's the palikan and the tribitaka
what are these well they're the holy
books
of um of Buddhism
imagine you find a Christian you know
somewhere in the you say uh or say for
example Catholic right
and you say what I'm a Catholic oh
you're a Catholic yeah
but I don't believe in in the Bible
how can you be a Catholic and not
believe in the Bible
I mean this is your holy book
so you cannot say that you you believe
that you are a Christian but you don't
believe in the Bible
and that's more or less what the
Buddhists are trying to say here they
don't believe in God but they believe in
the tripitaka
so is there any notion of God or gods or
anything similar to God's maybe Angels
Saints uh spirits in the religion of
Buddhism
but here it is okay here we have them
this is the tripitaka the one one of the
Buddhist Bibles or the main one I guess
and there you will find at least one
fellow his name is Myron that's what
they call him he's the Buddhist devil
uh double is uh is a mean individual
mean God okay
and in fact that's a stone picture uh
Stone statue that they found of this uh
Mara fellow okay and yeah he he does a
lot of evil in the world okay so he's an
anthropomorphic God that the Buddhists
have because it's included in the
tripitaka which is one of the or the
main Buddhist Bible
so if you're a Buddhist and you believe
in the tripitaka you cannot say well
there is no God and conversely you can't
say well we don't believe in God but I
do believe in the tripitaka which is my
Bible
okay so you see where the contradiction
is in fact uh constantly you'll find all
kinds of pictures in Buddhism here's one
of them okay and they show uh this sixth
armed Mara the evil one okay and uh This
Is How They portray him like a you know
I mean do you know of any human has six
arms
maybe there is one out there maybe in
the Amish community you know but no um
uh you know the tripitaka does have uh
ghosts and goblins and uh spirits and
gods okay and uh here's one that there's
your your illustration of one this is uh
what you'll find out there okay they
they put this Mara fellow okay he's a
god of evil who tempted apparently the
Buddha okay just like the devil
attempted God same little stories
so you know they have had God's two
thousand years ago
okay
and three thousand and More in fact uh
you know we had uh what we call Greek
mythology and they had a God for every
purpose
okay so when religion started they had
many gods they didn't know what the wind
was they didn't know because they
couldn't see it you know they didn't
know what rain was or so they had a God
for every purpose then later on they
came up with mono uh the theism they
started having one God but then they
some religion started having Angels you
know like the uh Christians uh some
Christian denominations uh same with
Muslims you know they they believe in
angels and so they have one Angel for
every purpose you can you know you can
pray to one of the Angels one of your
favorite angels maybe he'll listen to
you and do something for you you know
that sort of thing
so but that was hundreds of years ago
you talk about the generation today
Buddhists Hindus
um Muslims Christians
and it's a different world
and you stop a guy on the street who's a
Christian who's a maybe a Catholic or
whatever Orthodox and he might say well
I don't believe in that part of the
Bible
I don't believe in create I don't
believe God created the universe maybe
you know or that he created Adam and Eve
maybe he believes in evolution but he he
calls himself a Christian
well we got a problem because you know
either you're a Christian meaning the
original Christians the ones who call
themselves Christian
or you change the religion and you
became something else but you didn't
realize and you continued calling
yourself Christian
why
well I'll tell you why because they want
to have the history of the book they say
oh our religion has been around for
thousands of years
and here's the book to prove it
and that's on the one hand but then on
the other they say oh but we don't
believe in anything that's in that book
because we have a new religion today
but they continue calling themselves
Buddhist hinduists Muslims Christians
so we have a problem the people of today
are no longer Christians or no longer
Muslims are no longer Buddhists or or
hinduists what they are is something
else than what people a thousand two
thousand years ago were those people
believed exactly in the literal Bible in
their literal tripitaka or whatever they
believed in that stuff they believed
there were some evil spirits rolling
around but today a lot of people
especially the Young Generation a lot of
them don't believe in all that stuff but
they say I'm a Buddhist why are you a
Buddhist well my father took me to
church and I prayed and whatever so they
were raised in a Buddhist environment or
a Hindu environment and they learned by
wrote by authority to respect the
Customs the traditions and the religion
some things they like some things they
don't sometimes most of the time they
don't even read their holy books but
they swear on them you know and so on so
these people are no longer Buddhists
they're no longer Christians they're no
longer anything they've got new
religions today
just like you know when religion changed
from
polytheistic to monotheistic likewise
today we have different religions that
have nothing to do with what happened
two thousand years ago okay this is the
issue
all religions started by believing in
God Buddhists change that now they're
emphasizing Behavior rather than you
know they're Gods but their gods are in
their holy books and they still you know
treat their books as holy period we're
done you know Buddhists do believe in
God the traditional Buddhist the the
authentic Buddhist everybody else is not
a Buddhist they're they should call
themselves something else
okay and uh here you have a definition
of Buddhist okay just in case I'm
picking on the Buddhist because they're
the ones who claim that they don't
believe in God okay okay here's a
theravada Buddhism Buddha refers to one
who has become enlightened aha through
their own efforts and insight I
typically do it with a couple beers okay
but yeah a Buddha someone who has
realized the enlightenment that ends the
cycle of birth and death
so a Buddha the guy who's achieved
Enlightenment he no longer dies or is
born I guess he lives forever meaning
he's a God so the guy who calls himself
a Buddha there's 28 of them apparently
in history and I don't know where
they're at because if they're not dead I
guess they're alive somewhere or
whatever uh you know if uh if a Buddha
is is a guy who reached Enlightenment no
longer is subject to death or rebirth I
guess he lives forever meaning he's a
god Buddha is the same thing as God in
the Pali Canon uh it is stated that
Buddhas have appeared in the past and
will also appear in the future okay so
now we're talking about this God coming
to Earth I guess Jesus Christ you know
he he achieved Enlightenment or he's the
son of God or whatever now he's going to
come in the future and the third
millennium maybe who knows
there were also numerous enlightened
Buddhas who arose in earlier World
Cycles aha so we've had a pre pre-World
worlds uh Buddhas and the name of these
28 Buddhas are religiously preserved by
Buddhists okay so these people do
believe in Gods they're known as Buddhas
the Buddha is a synonym of God it's a
what is a god it's a guy who lives
forever who has uh superpowers meaning
in this case that they achieved
Enlightenment whatever that is
uh maybe not physical but uh mental you
know the Consciousness stuff and so they
say you know I'm a Buddha I've achieved
Enlightenment I've seen the light
so I'm a Buddha too I've seen the light
it looks like this okay and I did that
with two beers
okay anyways uh let's find out what
religion is according to the definitions
today here's the religion according to
the dictionary a set of beliefs
concerning the cause nature and purpose
of the universe especially when
considered as the creation of a what
superhuman agency or agencies
okay so they're talking about superhuman
Supernatural
transcendental okay religion the belief
in and worship of a superhuman
controlling power at bestie a personal
God or Gods that's according to the
Oxford dictionary again you can see that
they relate belief in God they put those
two words together and that's
essentially what the notion that people
have of religion Wikipedia says a social
cultural system of designated behaviors
and practices morals beliefs World
reviews texts Sanctified places
prophecies ethics or organizations that
generally relates Humanity to what
Supernatural transcendental and
spiritual elements I think that is a
more generic definition the one in the
wikipedias I think it's a notion closer
to the person who does research on
religion in general you know the the
normal guy things like the Oxford
dictionary it's belief in God the person
who does a little more research he said
well it's not exactly belief and God
even though the Buddhists also believe
in God but assuming it in it doesn't
matter it's a it's more like the belief
in the transcendental in the
Supernatural
okay so we need to find out what these
words mean if we're going to get to the
bottom of the word religion and we're
going to distinguish it for example from
mathematical physics I mean is that
religion or is that science
okay well science science explanations
rational explanations okay here we have
um traditional religion so we can
summarize this uh they propose that
there are transcendental anthropomorphic
being spirits that intervene in human
Affairs that's more or less their notion
um you can instead of beans you can put
in their things objects uh you know but
it's related to the transcendental okay
uh and we'll get to that in a second
what that means okay and here we have
the modern religion we can call them uh
in the question whether they're
religions at all what is general
relativity proposes that the cosmic
World consists of an unimaginable
four-dimensional mathematical entity
okay and quantum mechanics proposes that
the subatomic world is mediated by
reified Concepts such as wave function
collapse
Okay so or fields or energy okay there
you have examples uh general relativity
says that this is four-dimensional
space-time why didn't I put something in
there well because we cannot imagine
four-dimensional space time we uh what
what am I supposed to draw okay
uh and uh here we have uh quantum
mechanics says this is energy what am I
supposed to draw for energy
okay so again it's unimaginable and
that's different than what you see on
the left where you know the gut of the
wind it always uh got himself uh the one
from the Christians Spirits angels we
can draw those you know you can draw
Casper the Friendly Ghost and say that's
a spirit that's a ghost we can draw
those we can make images of those what
image are you going to make of a
four-dimensional space time what image
are you going to make of energy what are
you going to put on the screen for the
you know for the congregation to see
so so we got a problem the question is
is uh general relativity or quantum
mechanics do they even belong in
religion or do we have a new category
you know we had religion traditional
religions that they said they believed
in the transcendental objects cons uh
objects
um Gods Spirits Angels whatever you want
to call them
so they say these Spirits these Gods
they're acting in our world they're
interfering in our world they they make
us think they they know what we're
thinking they uh listen to our prayers
they concede
um
gifts or whatever you request sometimes
sometimes they don't because they're
angry at us whatever so but we can we
can picture all this we can say okay
this is the god this is the Angel this
is the spirit and this guy is acting in
our lives somehow by remote control by
Magic no problem but we can visualize
all that we can visualize the part that
they're referring to the God the spirit
the angel
in mathematical physics you cannot even
visualize the entities that they claim
are performing all the Miracles out
there like gravity magnetism electricity
Etc we cannot visualize it because you
can't they're all Concepts that have
been reified
so what are you going to put in there
so we we may have a new category that we
cannot really call religion uh my son
ends uh he'll probably be here next week
and he says it's uh we should call it
um what is it um
uh
uh
let me see if I can remember yeah
it's a
but we'll Escape my mind
um
[Laughter]
oh okay I have to pass because I can't
remember the word now
um
not getting the tip of my tongue I can't
remember it's what happens when you get
too old okay you get cough like I've had
all these days uh I've also got on this
I started the other day
um get a smudge that's moving around a
floater and you get a little Alzheimer's
to go with it
um anyways uh it's it's Authority
essentially you know you believe in
authority and someone just tells you
that space time is four dimensional and
that's what causes gravity and you just
say uh-huh and that's it because you
know this is what they teach you by
wrote
that's what I want that's the word that
I couldn't remember Nasi they're Nazis
like Hitler you know they're Nazis uh
what is it they tell you you gotta
believe in this you gotta do this and
you just do it you believe it
and that's it for mathematical physics
so you know it's uh it's this abstract
World which they made into a concrete
World they reified the concepts and
that's a little different than
traditional religions uh to a certain
degree you know if you talk about uh God
being a spirit God be in love God being
Lo uh you know intelligence or anything
like that a concept energy you know then
you're doing the same thing but if you
say that God is anthropomorphic that the
spirit is anthropomorphic and that the
uh Angel you know has wings and a little
plate on his head then you're talking
about a real entity that you can make an
image of you can't do that with anything
coming out of mathematical physics
therefore you cannot give a physical
interpretation because of that because
you don't have any physical any objects
to do the mechanism with okay
okay so uh yeah in a way we have to
distinguish the supernatural from the
irrational okay and so here we have
Supernatural uh theories such as the
traditional religions Christianity Islam
Judaism Etc you know and you have uh
they they believed in this
transcendental world and then you have
irrational theories like mathematical
physics okay and general relativity
quantum mechanics uh modern philosophy
atheism okay agnosticism ontology
metaphysics oh these are uh irrational
theories uh why because they make
um all Concepts they turn them into
objects they reify them that's that's
when it becomes irrational and in that
sense they're different than the
supernatural okay so what's the
difference between irrational
and uh so Supernatural well here it is
criteria for irrational is that you're
treating Concepts as physical objects
that's that's essentially what
mathematical physics does in that sense
you can say well it is a religion uh it
relies a lot on belief you know
mathematicians talk a lot about belief
but that's not what distinguishes it
from traditional religions what what
changes there is that
um the modern religions if we call them
religions of general relativity quantum
mechanics strength Theory mathematical
physics in general that includes also
all the
flat lenders such as you know flat
earthers
etheris
the electric universers John Chappelle
group all these people they're the same
boat you know they they are irrational
theories because uh all these uh you
know dissidents they've copied the
entities or the wording of mathematical
physics they use the word energy they
use the word charge they use the word
field wave you know they use all the
same language and that's why they're
irrational as well and yeah what you're
doing is you're
criticizing a concept you're reifying a
concept you're turning it into a
physical object that's the main one
there's other couple others you know
where the you have no definition people
say that's word solid as one guy
suggested or they have undefined words
okay ether is the main one we discussed
today okay so uh yeah uh what we're
saying is that maybe there's a
difference between the religions of the
last hundred years general relativity
and quantum mechanics specifically with
respect to traditional religions in that
they reify Concepts and that's a little
different than having an anthropomorphic
God or angel or spirit
okay
okay we also have our science critic
okay and uh this fellow in this uh talk
today he talked about space time
is there such a thing as space-time
four-dimensional space-time is it a
thing
can we visualize space-time
if space-time is a concept
can we visualize a concept
that's more or less what this fellow was
talking about when he criticized one of
my videos
and here goes let me show you his his
part of it okay and and then we'll
discuss it here it goes pay attention
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
is general relativity space-time a
rational physical interpretation for
gravity
and is it possible to visualize a
mathematical concept such as space-time
I mean there is space-time and the sun
does warp that space-time so that does
cause the Earth to move around the Sun
so there is a justification I suppose we
can try and visualize it which we have
done with space time there's a whole lot
of different visualizations for that but
again whether you can visualize it or
not has no bearing on what's actually
happening
hmm
okay
so this fellow believes in space-time he
believes that's an explanation a
mechanistic explanation for Gravity okay
so he defends space-time
and so let's first uh go with uh an
expert on space time his name was
Stephen Hawking died a couple years ago
this is what Steve had to say in his
book A Brief History of Time
it is impossible to imagine a
four-dimensional space
okay
and so he says you cannot even visualize
this
but people attempt to do so anyways and
here's a typical scenario that people
present you'll see this quite often just
about everywhere just put space time in
Google especially images and you'll find
something along these lines okay and
here you'll see it the moon going around
the earth why because the Earth pushes
down space time that's that blue uh
checkered uh
ground on which the Earth is sitting
there this ridiculous two-dimensional
platform or a canvas or whatever that
when the earth pushes downwards turns
into a three-dimensional canvas you know
trampoline uh fishnet whatever you want
to call it and none of that is four
dimensional so we're not looking at four
dimensional anything the best we can see
there is three-dimensional okay
and this is the explanation that they
have for Gravity why the moon doesn't
fall run out of the solar system or out
of the earth it's because it's rolling
around forever in this depression in
space-time so on the one hand we have Mr
Hawking he says you cannot visualize
space-time and here you have these
people and they say look we we can
visualize it and what we're visualizing
is nothing that is remotely related to
four-dimensional it's a two-dimensional
warped canvas that turns into three
dimensions at best
and so that's not space time space time
is four dimension where are the four
dimensions okay so yeah you cannot
visualize four dimensions but this all
believes that it has been Illustrated
yeah you probably saw something like
that and says oh yeah I saw space time
now you can't see space time because
first of all it's a concept and he
doesn't even realize that he doesn't
realize that the word time is a concept
you cannot what are you going to
illustrate for time a second a minute a
year what are you going to put for time
on the on the screen what are you going
to show people
okay so you cannot visualize time time
is the fourth leg of space time
obviously you cannot visualize a concept
such as space time here these people are
illustrating it with this ridiculous
two-dimensional canvas that turns into
3D again it's not a representation of
the 4D at all
Hawking tells you you cannot even
imagine four-dimensional space-time
so I don't know why these people are
even trying to give
to illustrate space-time why don't they
just do math and stay with math that
that'd be fine we wouldn't even hear
about them but see they want to tell you
that they understand why the moon
doesn't fly out of out of the Earth or
out of solar system out of the orbit
right or the Earth out of the Sun
they tell you that they know they know
why it doesn't because space-time is
worked and you say well you show me show
me the picture
and they said well we can't show you
it's an analogy
see this is the problem the problem is
their analogy is you cannot even
visualize you cannot even imagine their
analogy that's the problem they cannot
illustrate it and so yeah it's important
to be able to illustrate these theories
because then you can see the mechanism
right now we can't see the mechanism
because we see the mechanism for a
three-dimensional object now for a four
dimensional one therefore we don't see
the the
um
what is it we don't see the analogy
is is a flat disc rolling around flat
land an analogy also for
four-dimensional space-time
okay what's keeping the flat disc from
flying out
okay in two-dimensional flat land okay
is that an analogy also so again these
people have no answers and when you try
to do that you know when you try to use
these
pictures to try to simulate it they
laugh at you anyways and here's uh this
is uh from The Establishment says
understanding gravity space time is like
a rubber Sheen
[Music]
um
massive objects distort the sheet and
and the student says uh they distort
because they are pulled down by what
and the teacher says well space-time is
like this set of equations
for which any analogy must be an
approximation
so yeah they don't have an explanation
their analogy is worthless garbage okay
straight through Straight said the way
it should be said it's garbage okay it's
it's Poppy Kai but the question why do
they even attempt to give a physical
interpretation if they know they can't
even visualize what they're saying
I mean they should stick to equations
and leave it at that but when they when
they try to give you an explanation
that's when they cross the line into
physics they tell you they know because
they did their equations and now they're
giving you their personal interpretation
of their equations
and for that matter we can introduce God
and the angels and Spirits as well no
problem
okay so what is the conclusion for uh
this space-time thingy okay here we have
it in physics it is irrational to reify
a concept and treat it as an object
space-time is a mathematical concept as
such it is irrational and misleading to
represent it with a fishnet in general
relativity gravity is equal to warp
space-time in physics only objects okay
only objects
can be warped or bent because warped is
a word that can only be applied to
objects when you say that the hammock is
Warped hopefully you have a hammock hope
you have a thing there okay and these
people are warping a concept
specifically the cars the concept known
as time how do you warp time
okay how do you bend time how do you uh
break it in half okay and therefore
general relativity does not have a
physical interpretation of gravity and
what you should ask yourself is why did
the relativists even try to give a
physical interpretation for gravity or
for how this universe works if they have
a description mathematical description
no problem just keep it within math and
don't ever bring it into physics it's
when they cross the line into physics
that they have allowed people like me to
question what they're proposing and when
they lose when they you know they have
no way of defending them so they say
well that's philosophy anyways so they
dismiss it anyways
okay so moving on here
we have some questions that people asked
comments that people made here's the
first one Phil says energies have shape
energies have shame
as an object increases in speed so does
the amount of energy
oh hold it uh what do you mean amount
I thought you just said that energy has
she meaning it's a thing draw it for us
first of all but what do you mean the
amount of shape
what has increased
okay so again these people will use uh
this word salad they're using word salad
semante because they're using nonsense
it's idiocy what these people are saying
idiocy what is it big ideas that's what
it is okay energy is referred to as
inertial mass
Mass can't go faster
yeah if energy is a concept then
obviously mass is a concept you know
it's very difficult to accelerate a
concept so I don't know how this value
pretends to accelerate a mass when mass
is not a physical object you can say
that he's going to accelerate a ball he
can accelerate maybe you know a cube an
elephant whatever a house but he cannot
accept
accelerate a concept such as mass or
energy okay so again it's these people
who have this word Wizardry word salad
they're using word salad and it all
comes from mathematical physics which
was driven into their brains you know in
high school college wherever
okay Phil says light does not require a
medium
but motion you know two locations of a
medium that's what motion is otherwise
you got to Define what uh motion is okay
because if light moves in any way shape
or form then it had better be a medium
okay
any medium slows it down
well we don't care about that because
the medium through which light travels
has nothing to do with a medium that is
doing the traveling so this individual
is confusing the medium that light is
with a medium light is traveling through
okay so these are two different issues
the question is whether light uh itself
has a medium that represented that is
doing the the motion and hopefully it
does because motion requires an object a
medium so how can you have motion
without a medium what is moving
so uh yeah these people go around in
circles and when they lose uh you know
they they can't answer the questions
they say ah you're doing philosophy
you're doing word salad you're doing
word Wizardry Etc you know because they
can't defend their their posture that's
what it is okay well it says if I can't
see electricity what's lightning
okay so he thinks that uh because he
sees lightning he's staring at
electricity yeah but see lightning uh we
look it up it says a brilliant Electric
discharge
discharge what is this charge is this
there's a physical object that you can
see well no this church is to rid of
charge of electricity according to
dictionary.com uh what is uh it
according to Wikipedia discharges flow
of something flow of current so
discharge is a verb and you can't see
verbs okay because verbs are Concepts
okay so uh we can't see Concepts in this
case Dynamic Concepts and so you can
when you look at lightning what you're
looking at is a movie
you know you can't see lightning in a
single picture because that's not
lightning okay that's just a flash
um that's just a light okay that you've
taken a picture of lightning is
something in motion because it's a
discharge and discharge is either rid of
charge or flow of current okay so you
can't see verbs okay that's what you're
saying it says does lightning have shape
making it an object no lightning does
not have shape because lightning is in
motion anything in motion does not have
shape shape is a static concept you have
to take a snapshot of lightning when you
do so you do not have lightning because
lightning is defined
as discharge which is a verb okay so you
can't take a picture of running if you
take a picture of running what you have
in the picture is a boy standing up in
the air somewhere okay
that's what you have and a boy standing
is not running
and you say well but he's got his legs
one in front of the other yeah I know
I'm sorry but running is a dynamic
concept known as a verb okay and so you
can't say that running that you're gonna
take a picture of running or that you
saw running not in physics in ordinary
speech you can say whatever you want in
irrational mathematical physics you can
say anything you want not in physics in
physics we do word salad we do semantics
okay whatever you want to call it you
have to Define your terms uh perfectly
rigidly so that no one can go off on a
tangent okay and so he says we can see
and touch electricity
well if you can see your touch
electricity you could tell us what
electricity is is it the flow of
electron beads
well if it's a flow of whatever you
cannot see you can watch it not see it
see you see a picture watch you watch a
movie okay and touch I don't know how
you can touch electricity but you know
maybe maybe he can maybe he's got super
um
Powers you know maybe like God
does the the fact make it an object okay
uh yeah no it doesn't because C and
touch have nothing to do with being an
object it's got to have shape shape is a
static concept electricity is not
I invite you to stick your tongue in a
light socket
so this all proves objects such as what
he thinks is electricity or Lightning by
sticking his tongue in a socket hey can
you believe that
he says he's going to prove that
electricity is an object by sticking out
his tongue
hahaha
my God poor fella okay here's another
file says if the magic rope is the
invisible and intangible lines between
atoms and the black stuff is where atoms
are not okay then by transitive property
we can conclude that the black stuff and
Magic rope is the same thing
oh my God so these poor souls they
cannot tell the difference between rope
and space he's saying rope is equal to
space by his wet transitive property
intelligence logic whatever he thinks
that is anyways uh no a rope is not
equal to space rope is what connects any
two atoms space is what gives shape to
both the rope and the atom space is
nothing space is the backdrop that gives
shape to every orb you can say kind of
cuts off objects from objects if space
weren't there that separator that thing
that kind of distinguishes one object
from another uh we would have a single
block of matter in the universe and yeah
that object would be infinite made of a
single piece because it would not have
space to chop it into the pieces we call
atoms okay just as simple as that
and then final issue false says can we
reduce all signs to a firm distinction
in other words both a concept and an
object can be intangible
okay so let's clarify this all concepts
are invisible and intangible you cannot
see or touch a concept you cannot touch
running you cannot touch electricity you
cannot touch lightning or see it okay
because these are Dynamic Concepts okay
they're verbs you know can't see verbs
you can't see running you can't see
flying you can't see swimming
you can watch it you can watch a movie
of swimming but what are you watching
you're watching uh if you're watching
flying you're watching a bird if you're
watching uh or an airplane uh maybe
Superman if you're watching running it
could be a human maybe you're watching
Galloping a horse okay if you're
watching swimming you're seeing a fish
if you take a snapshot of that that's
not of any of those you don't you're not
you don't have a snapshot of flying uh
running or of swimming what you have is
a snapshot of a bird a human or a fish
okay so you can't confuse fish
with swimming you can't confuse human
with running you can't confuse bird with
flying and that's what this these
fellows do when they confuse electricity
with motion
okay with with an object they say
electricity is an object a thing I can
take a snapshot of it I can touch it no
you can't you can touch a table you
cannot touch running you can't you can
touch the ball you can cannot touch
running okay electricity is running
something's happening it's a verb it's a
dynamic concept so it's plasma
so is ether
so is uh what was it lightning all those
are motion
you can't just you can't touch what is
in motion you can touch the object not
the motion it's doing
which is what these people are doing
saying
some objects are tangible but invisible
okay some objects are tangible but
invisible I can touch the air but I
cannot see the air okay some objects are
visible but intangible
okay you say how can that possibly be
yeah the nearest star Alpha Centauri
it's visible but you can't touch it and
say well because I'm not close enough
well we don't know until you touch it
will we okay and uh some objects are
invisible and intangible you can't see
the table that the Klingon has on the
other side of the universe okay so uh
it's invisible and intangible to for us
therefore
uh we can't say a table is not an object
because I can't see or touch it the
Klingons table so uh table is always the
word table always represents a physical
object okay we're tear the word tree the
word rock all those are objects why is
it because I can see you touch them
certainly not the tree that's on the
other side of the universe they are
objects because they have shape and now
we can apply the the word uh the
definition uh consistently across the
board
with that I'll see you next week next
Sunday and hopefully I'll feel better
with my